big tech trying to permanently silence
conservatives in america
and control what you're allowed to see
and hear republicans are furious
and threatening retaliation after
facebook's oversight board
upheld its indefinite ban on former
president trump
they're warning if it can happen to him
it can happen to anybody
but this story is much bigger than just
one person it's about
tech oligarchs manipulating the
political conversation and debate
republicans say it's time to take action
it's a sad day for america it's a sad
day for facebook
because i can tell you a number of
members of congress
are now looking at do they break up
facebook we can't allow a corporation to
do something that we don't allow
the united states government to do and
and it's just it's contrary to our
american values
congress needs to get up off its
ice-cold lazy butt
and face this issue head-on
and both democrats and republicans
understand something's wrong
the battle over big tech bias doesn't
end there florida governor ron desantis
has been working on a bill that would
fine social media companies
for banning political candidates and
senator josh hawley is leading the
charge to hold big tech accountable
i think big tech is just very arrogant
if you're someone that's been censored
unfairly or to platform
we're giving you the ability to sue big
tech yourself what we need
is real competition why do these
companies get by with ignoring
75 million americans and trying to
censor them it's because they don't have
any real competition and this is what we
have monopoly laws for this is what
trust busting's for
it's to open up space for competition
okay let's begin with greg gutfeld who
has his glasses on so i expect a
very intellectual conversation greg
what was your reaction when you saw that
they upheld it
and they kicked it back to facebook i
was deeply distraught
jesse i went home and i cried yeah no
you know i'm not surprised look i mean
you're gonna get the argument the
predictable argument that this is a
private company so it's not a speech
issue
but in that argument you realize the
ship has already sailed we're not
we understand it this isn't talk this
isn't about going up to a street corner
and shouting
all right social media platforms are so
huge
that when you get kicked off it it's not
you can go start one off start a new one
up in your backyard that would be like
starting the phone company in the 1990s
or 1980s because they won't let you use
the telephone um so i think that the
people that are okay with this
it's pure partisanship they're not
conservative so this isn't a problem
it's like when people laugh
about when you talk about media bias or
you talk about bias in academia or you
talk about bias in the entertainment
industry
the left the democrats uh the people in
the press they don't care because it
doesn't affect them
but one day it will affect them when
they find out that they're not left-wing
enough
and i'm telling you these social media
platforms and places like google they do
control
the narrative if you've ever tried to
search for a story
that you were looking for specifically
that had a conservative idea in it good
luck
because the algorithms do not help you
and and also i do think that like
i do think twitter really suffers from
not having somebody like trump on there
it's like van halen losing david lee
roth
or you know or maybe it's more like the
sugar cubes when bjork left
and the band just collapsed there's
nothing interesting on twitter anymore
we have a trump-sized hole we need to
fill and i don't necessarily believe
from the desk of donald trump
is the right way to do it because it
feels like a memo from your uncle
whereas he was america's cab driver when
he was on twitter it was like this
ongoing
assessment of your daily life that i
actually kind of miss
and i wonder if you googled from the
desk of donald trump you'd have to
search really really hard for that to
pop up
yeah dana perino always good with
predictions so the oversight committee
sent it back zuckerberg is going to have
to figure this out
and they didn't really like the
indefinite ban
but where do we go from here what's
going to happen next
we're kind of in status quo right well
you know the board could have said
uphold the ban but instead now they're
back
you know go back and they said well you
know in your rules it doesn't say you
can have an indefinite ban you either
have to do it or not
and so um we're kind of like right where
we were
um compared to for example twitter which
just said banned
done and there is no oversight board
there is no discussion about it
um and so i i think when it comes to
washington dc what will it do
you know greg brings up the phone
company and i think it's a really good
point like you can't just cut off
somebody's phone service because
that you don't like what what they have
to say or even if you're
crank calling people like we know
somebody on this panel used to do all
the time after school
and i tried it myself i wasn't very good
at it but you can't do that um
but the way it's set up right now under
the law they are not considered a
utility
um could they be i mean is that the
direction to go because
actually that you could probably get to
some bipartisan consensus
bernie sanders at one point had said
that he didn't think this policy was a
good one
he could see the principal danger
here so it's possible you could do that
in the meantime this is what's going to
happen
tons of fundraising from both sides
republicans and democrats figuring out a
way to try to get people to donate money
and still i would imagine a year from
now
nothing has changed kennedy do you agree
you think both parties are gonna
beat this drum and then whenever either
one of them gets any power
they do nothing about it it'll be
interesting to see because this is one
of the few
issues where there actually is a great
deal of bipartisan crossover
and i would be curious to see i don't
think i would like it but i would
i'd be curious to see what senators josh
hawley and elizabeth warren would come
up with
if they got together to talk about their
big tech grievances
because i don't think they're too far
apart from each other they both talked
about
breaking up these behemoth companies and
you know to greg's point
uh remember when google was threatening
to essentially de-platform
the federalists so they would no longer
be able to advertise
through google platforms and that would
have killed their business
and facebook i think this oversight
board is just a way for mark zuckerberg
to not have to take responsibility
so he's he's just delegating it to some
other faceless blob so they don't really
do anything
and i also remember when dana went to
the facebook campus because for a while
they were paying lip service
to conservatives they had acknowledged
that conservatives
were being frozen out of at least their
platform and
obviously that you know that was just
for show that is not happening anymore
so uh if if you're looking at the
florida model maybe you have to end
qualified immunity for big tech
companies
yeah you mentioned the oversight board
at facebook i checked into it look at
who they stacked it with
former editor of the guardian former law
clerk for justice stevens
former prime minister of sweden social
democrat pakistani lawyer kenyan lawyer
indonesian journalist
former judge at the european court of
human rights
i'm not disparaging these people i just
looked at their little bios but
juan just by that glance i wouldn't call
that mega country would you
i didn't know that was the measure of it
i think they they wanted people who knew
something about the industry jesse and
people who could come to
had the basis the experience uh to reach
a
logical decision i thought it was you
know pretty good decision
let me just comfort all of you this is
not about conservatives
not at all this is about the truth you
can't yell
fire in a crowded theater and if you're
president of the united states
you can't yell fraud and say oh this is
fraud because i lost an election when in
fact
you lost the election you can't do that
you lost the election
no you can't say that because you know
what you're going to
let me tell you why you can't say it let
me tell you why people would sanction
not conservatives but donald trump
because he said it
he perpetrated a lie that led to
violence that's what happened with
that's your opinion
what happened with facebook that's your
opinion that's telling you we could cut
that no
we operate under your assumptions
let me just say something greg you asked
twitter
and you asked facebook what they'll tell
you is
the fact that he lied and it and it
created violence
the insurrection at the capitol this was
what prompted them to say we need to
sanction
donald trump not control
oh it's not true it's not about opinion
it's about a fact that what happened
in fact it was directly talking about
what's
truth is not about you know somehow it's
republican
somehow it's uh what about democrat
no it the truth is the truth and somehow
donald trump tells a ongoing lie that
has damaged our country
threatens our democracy and people are
saying
this is too threatening to us as a
society and you should not use our
platform to spread the word
right now you have she's gonna ban the
lies right now you have
you have liz cheney being forced out
because she won't buy him
this is this is crazy what is going on
with the republican party that's so
funny
kills me juan no one can hear what
you're saying but you're wrong
because facebook actually banned trump
because it actually broke their protocol
that you can't
praise people who are committing
violence because he called the people on
the sixth
patriots it wasn't anything about saying
fraud or anything like that
that was the technicality just so the
audience knows the truth it was a lie
you got to go next it was a lie and
that's why is cheney right now
we gotta go why are you screaming man
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else